según el último estudio de la ocde
solamente el 17 por ciento de la
población mexicana cuenta con una
carrera profesional te platico que es de
chica yo estaba decidida a ser toda una
profesionista pero la vida tenía otros
planes para mí y es que cuando tenía 17
años mi hermano mayor se broncoaspiró
para los que no sepan qué es esto
prácticamente se le cerró la garganta y
no podía respirar y pues bueno tuvo que
estar varios días en cuidados intensivos
lamentablemente dado este acontecimiento
mi papá tuvo que tener una penosa
conversación conmigo que terminó con un
mira no sé ni cómo voy a apagar este
hospital lo único que te tengo que decir
es que necesitas empezar a ver qué hacer
porque estudiar pues no si adelantamos
el tiempo seis años después de esa
conversación me estaba graduando de la
carrera con honores a los 20 años logré
comprar mi primer kart y hoy con 18 años
de carrera profesional
soy socia de diversas empresas se dice
fácil no pero hubo muchos días en donde
quería tirar la toalla donde mucha gente
a mi alrededor no creía que lo lograría
y también porque soy mujer sentía que
tenía que hacer un doble esfuerzo porque
si fracasaba nadie iba a decir ella no
pudo lograrlo dirán las mujeres no
pueden lograrlo
hoy estoy convencida que fueron todas
esas pequeñas decisiones que tome todos
los días lo que me ayudó a determinar mi
futuro y si siempre tuve una gran
maestra la necesidad uno no escoge lo
que le sucede en la vida pero si somos
100% responsables de cómo actuamos ante
ella quiero platicarte que uno de mis
primeros trabajos fue en una empresa de
telecomunicaciones y empecé ya sabes
contestando llamadas hola gracias por
llamar nuestra compañía mi nombre es
ahora valdés en donde te puedo ayudar y
bueno así estaba desde que empezaba
hasta que salía y después aplique para
la reclutadora de campo y me dieron el
puesto quede seleccionada y al llegar a
mi nuevo trabajo ayer mi nuevo puesto me
di cuenta que teníamos una rotación
altísima y que la mayoría éramos
estudiantes o con carrera trunca
entonces se me ocurre hacer un proyecto
en donde podríamos hacer convenios con
la mayoría de las universidades para que
nos dieran una beca única para la
empresa y así podríamos ayudar a los
colaboradores
estudiando y también prolongar la vida
del colaborador en la empresa utilizando
la beca que tendrían con nosotros
entonces pues prácticamente lo que hice
fue armar mi proyecto y voy muy
entusiasmada con mi jefe el cual me dice
que no pero no se preocupen después fui
con su jefa que también me dijo que no y
la verdad es que no me quería dar por
vencida tan fácil entonces fui con el
director de recursos humanos unos días
después para pedirles cinco minutos para
contarle mi idea y aceptó cuando termine
se me quedó viendo sin decirme nada
por momento pensé que me iba a correr
y en eso me dice cuando empezamos y yo
no pues ya y empecé a hacer toda la
logística a hablar con las universidades
y empezamos a firmar con la mayoría de
las universidades de nuevo léon aún no
puedo creer que el programa tiene más de
10 años y ha ayudado a muchísimos
jóvenes a poder trabajar y estudiar con
una beca me lleno de mucho orgullo e
ilusión que aunque trabajarlo y sacarlo
adelante no fue nada sencillo hoy sigue
dando muchos frutos me tocó también la
fortuna de trabajar en una empresa de
tecnologías de información para los que
han estado reclutando talento de ti
saben que es un mercado muy competido
así que bueno estaba tratando de pensar
fuera de la caja
en eso con o sin movimiento congruencia
y es una asociación que ayuda a jóvenes
con discapacidad a incorporarse al mundo
laboral y de ahí conocí a la universidad
tecnológica de santa catarina que es una
escuela que tiene chavos que están
estudiando sistemas en computación que
tenían todo lo que yo necesitaba para mi
vacante sólo que eran sordos
lo cual yo lo veía como una fortaleza
porque porque la diversidad es lo que
nos hace ver más allá lo que nos saca de
nuestra zona de confort lo que nos ayuda
a crear cosas nuevas y diferentes
inclusive que jamás nos hubiéramos
imaginado entonces preparo mi proyecto
muy entusiasmada voy con el director de
recursos humanos y bueno ustedes ya
saben cómo me fue no solamente rechazo
mi proyecto sino me pidió de favor que
ni siquiera lo volviera a comentar con
nadie la compañía
pero como ustedes ya me conocen pues eso
obviamente no sucedió entonces empecé a
citarlos para entrevista en la empresa y
me llamó mucho la atención que cuando lo
citaba por lo general iban acompañados
por su mamá y su papá me los llevaba
entrevista y al regresar con ellos había
un mensaje que me decían
mirad ahora no importa si no los
contratas hoy nos damos cuenta que
nuestro hijo tiene oportunidades
gracias por abrirnos los ojos
yo estaba sin palabras obviamente se me
salían las lágrimas con ellos y lo único
que hacía es que me daba más fuerza para
querer seguir hacia adelante con mi
proyecto fue a buscar a otro director y
le pedí si podíamos cubrir las vacantes
con ellos y él aceptó así que lancé el
programa sin autorización con un temor
enorme a que lo corrieran aún así decidí
arriesgarme y gracias a dios tuvo un
impacto muy positivo en toda la
organización
una de las personas que contratamos
gerardo fue asignado con rocío quien
tenía ya 12 años trabajando en la
empresa
al estar capacitando y entrenando a
gerardo rocío se da cuenta que su
verdadera vocación era la educación y la
inclusión de personas con discapacidad y
decide ponerse a estudiar un doctorado
en educación inclusiva
sale de la compañía y se dedica todo un
año a llevar a cabo un estudio de
inclusión laboral de profesionistas
sordos y la siguiente vez que los vi yo
en mi cocina muy agusto cenando fue en
un programa de televisión para
emprendedores solicitando capital para
su empresa que habían empezado juntos
no lo podía creer
ahí entendí que el impacto que yo puedo
causar en la cultura de una empresa o de
una persona es grandísimo y deje de ver
el trabajo como algo transaccional donde
uno solamente va ahí por dinero o por un
sueldo no quería desperdiciar mi tiempo
en un lugar en donde ni aportó ni me
aporta y empecé a hacer cada vez más
sincera conmigo
también entendí que cada empresa es
única tiene su propia razón de ser su
por qué y que no queremos imitar sino
más bien entender qué es lo que los
colaboradores y tu empresa necesita si
tienes una empresa recuerda que la
cultura determina el crecimiento o el
estancamiento de tu negocio y si no te
empeñas en crearla tú no te preocupes
sola se va a crear por la persona con
mayor carácter en tu organización y como
te puede tocar la dicha de que sea una
persona positiva y energética también
puede ser alguien negativo y
problemático tómate el tiempo de crear
la cultura que tu empresa necesita patri
creación y en su libro la ventaja nos
dice que hay dos cosas que requiere una
empresa para tener éxito la primera es
que dice que tiene que ser muy
inteligente y por inteligente se refiere
a una buena estrategia buena operación
buenas finanzas buen marketing y todo lo
que tradicionalmente conocemos y la
segunda es que tiene que tener salud y
por salud se refiere la cultura debes de
tener un equipo de trabajo de gran
talento las dos son requeridas
definitivamente pero de las dos la que
más impacto tiene a tu negocio es la
cultura y la razón por la cual lo dice
es porque no importa que tan brillante
sea tu estrategia tu empresa sólo
llegará tan lejos como tu gente te lleve
lamentablemente la mayoría de los dueños
y directores de negocio gastan más su
tiempo en la inteligencia y no en la
salud y basta con ver ejemplos como
google sapos netflix zoom
empresas que han sabido balancear entre
la inteligencia y la salud de su negocio
superando su competencia pues entienden
que la cultura es clave para el éxito de
su negocio ahora tener una buena
experiencia para tus colaboradores en tu
empresa no es un lujo es una necesidad
ya que aumentó un 31% de productividad
en tu gente y hace que permanezca en el
doble de tiempo enfocado en sus
actividades si trabajas para una empresa
esfuérzate por entender verdaderamente
su cultura de trabajo y no hablo de la
misión visión y valores sino de los
comportamientos que hay dentro esa es la
verdadera cultura
yo me pregunto
la cultura de la empresa en la que tú
trabajas resuena contigo
va con tu propósito de vida o no
comparte sus comportamientos y formas de
ser
y si algo no te gusta has intentado
cambiarlo levantar la mano hacer algo al
respecto
quiero invitarte a que te imagines
trabajar en una empresa con programas
flexibles para mamás programas para
gente con discapacidad
25 días de vacaciones desde el primer
día laboral 4 meses de maternidad y
paternidad totalmente pagados bonos por
casarte bonos por tener hijos poderte
ausentar en el cumpleaños de tus hijos
acceso a psicólogos inclusive mentores
que te ayuden a encontrar tu propósito
no nos hagamos chicos pensando que
porque estamos en méxico no podemos
implementar programas de primer mundo me
ha tocado la fortuna de poder
implementar aquí esto sin más programas
para diferentes empresas
hasta las preguntas difíciles sé honesto
y honesta contigo y no hagas lo que los
demás quieren o esperan de ti se
equivocan te errores vamos a cometer y
muchos y si te caes levántate si pierdes
acéptalo y aprende y si te llega un gran
reto profesional o personal nunca dudes
que tú tienes todo para sacarlo adelante
y por algo la vida te lo dio a ti sin
duda creo que cuando has encontrado tu
propósito no quiere decir que la vida
sea más fácil ni sencilla pero sí mucho
más clara ya paso firme y como bien
dicen el éxito suele ser el último
eslabón de una cadena de fracasos
transformemos todo lo que nos sucede en
fortaleza y sabiduría pues sólo estando
bien de manera individual es que podemos
sanamente conectar con nuestro alrededor
con nuestros seres más cercanos haciendo
las paces con nosotros mismos
descubre te equivocas te emociona te que
tus sueños y tus metas siempre sean más
grandes que tus miedos te invito a que
nunca dejes que la vida te lleve sino
que siempre seas tú quien lleve la vida
contigo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]